ce vendredi nouvel an chinois en france
à l'honneur cette année le buffle en
1984 c'était leur à une occasion toute
trouvée pour le journaliste yves
mourousi de ce monde et dit quelque
chose de gentil en chinois monsieur
donati j'en serais bien incapable et
roland la communauté asiatique
installé en france n'échappe à aucun
cliché écouté par exemple comment ce
journaliste décrivait les chinois en
1979 les chinois évoque toujours un nous
le mystère la complexité
la chine s'est toujours les baguettes la
porcelaine les estampes les dragons les
tapis les bouddhas après des baguettes
et les dragons place aux jeux de mots la
cible des restaurants chinois à rennes
villes comme rennes
deux cent mille habitants en comprend 4
c'est beaucoup
bien souvent ce ne sont pas des restes
en chinois mais vietnamiens à règne sur
les 4 un seul est tenu par des chinois
mais on y sert de la cuisine
vietnamienne encore un casse tête
chinois
bien sûr discret travailleur solitaire
voilà comment sont parfois perçus les
chinois en 1990 les chauffeurs de taxi
d'origine asiatique sont la cible de
ragots infondées on dit que les
chauffeurs de taxi asiatique ce relais
est que pendant qu'un un qui travaille
en a un qui dort dans le corps parce
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui dort jamais
personne ne dort dans votre corps jamais
en 2008
un restaurateur de limoges a fait les
frais du racisme anti-asiatique accusé
d'avoir servi du chien il a dû faire
appel aux services vétérinaires pour se
défendre
vous demandez s'il peut me fais
attestation ou quoi
notre établissement et aucune problème
ils sont venus plusieurs fois chez vous
2 3 fois par an et jamais eu aucun souci
les clichés se cumulent alimentées
parfois par la peur de l'immigration
asiatique le fameux péril jaune
une angoisse moqué dans ce reportage de
1967 qui imaginaient paris envahi par
les chinois ou à l inverse
attisé par les propos du leader
d'extrême droite jean marie le pen en
1996 aujourd'hui la pandémie venus de
chine a entraîné des accès de violence
contre la communauté asiatique point
d'orgue ces appels a agressé chaque
chinois qui ont circulé sur les réseaux
sociaux à l'automne dernier
[Musique]